hello and welcome to you honest trailer
commentary for Doctor Who modern edition
we done did it we finished we made it
I'm Spencer Jade Gilbert
that's lon Harris joestar's on vacation
so we brought in the big guns
we have our Doctor Who expert who helped
us in so many innumerable ways along the
journey Reilly J Silverman welcome I
love that I can actually say Doctor Who
expert is a credit of mine now oh it's a
career path yeah we yeah we leaned on
Reilly a lot she helped us with so many
stupid questions detailed questions like
is there a moment where doctor the
doctor contradicts themselves really
part of this process where it was like
we gotta figure out the rules so that
this all makes sense it then there was a
point like yeah and here's a clip where
they say there are no rules but if
you're unfamiliar this is the show where
we talk about the other show you
hopefully just watched the Australian
for Doctor Who modern not classic that's
a different video and in this one if you
do stick around we have so much that we
didn't make in the ground of the L will
see some deleted scenes and Wow like 13
years of a show that like even since the
return and now I'm like not to say the
Dan cut corners because it's far too
much for one man and he watched a
hundred 200 episodes easily but we
watched start to finish
modern who not all of us watched every
episode but we split it up and we a lawn
you got the tail end yes I watched the
the the ninth and 10th seasons in their
entire so the final two Capaldi seasons
but also jumped around as best I could
and tried to watch a little bit of
everything Joe did Eccleston and Tennant
and I did Matt Smith in a little bit of
Capaldi yes the first season and all
these fun Christmas specials in between
I wanted three Christmas specials yeah
so I I guess maybe we should just talk
about like what do you I know you think
of the show when you think of the show
wait do you like it I'm very divided in
this show I have to say more than almost
any other show I could think of I'm
really of two minds because there's a
lot
lot of stuff in it that I really like I
like British humor and that that's sort
of like twee kind of silly like it's a
good mix of high and low which the Brits
do very well it's like very smart and
clever and you need to really think
about it but then there's also really
dumb goofy stuff that happens and I like
that but I have to say like I I don't
the soap opera elements don't always
work for me and I feel it feels
sometimes it feels weird to juxtapose
like so much silliness and then right
away try to make me feel very emotional
I don't I don't know if that always
plays room okay look snuck up on me at
first I was watching it arms crossed
lean back and it didn't but eventually I
started I was surprised it started to
grow on me and by the time you're losing
companions and saying goodbye to doctors
I was like I'm getting emotional I don't
understand why Shou make me actually
attached to this ridiculous nothing
matters universe that we live in yeah I
think that's a fair point yeah but it's
you know American shows we were just
saying this a little before would never
do this like American shows are like
this is a hard-edged gritty crime
thriller and it's just that and it's
that beginning to end and it doesn't try
to like sneak up on you and do something
else yeah I do admire the fact that
there are really there's nothing the
show will say no to like you want to go
in a historical drama sure you want to
do something like a complete mind f a
sci-fi psychedelia thing sure we'll do
that too yeah there was a found-footage
horror movie in the middle of one to
another season enough episodes like what
else what happened we do yet know they
were really willing to take on any genre
yeah Beauty to is like especially in the
runs that y'all saw is like when the
show brings in writers they don't do
like a writers room like a lot of shows
do they basically would bring in a
writer and here's your episode go write
it so it was almost like hiring watch
people to write their own little like
short film or show one at the time like
David's like or now chip know I think
Shiva has a bit more of a writers room
atmosphere for his work but I think that
like typically they would go okay well
we're gonna like squeeze in our elements
and squeezing the things that make it
Doctor Who and like them know
but otherwise yes it does it kind of
feels like right there own little thing
again I'm sort of of two minds that are
like yeah it sort of makes some of the
episodes end up with like kind of a
patchwork feeling cuz you could tell
like well this service is Doctor Who and
this service is the individual story
this service is the ongoing but but I do
like that it gives it what it works it
gives it that really fun kind of
anthology feel like yeah like x-files at
its best have this feel where it's like
it doesn't miss it's the same show but
it doesn't feel the same every week and
like this week we're gonna get into this
kind of adventure and it's gonna have
this sort of feel like reading a short
story collection or something yeah I I
really appreciate this in the sense of
like even though it's a still going in a
modern show is like a real respect your
elders show because I like so many
things that are similar to Doctor Who
and I can now see the debt that they owe
to that and this is a weird
cross-pollination of like my favorite
thing in the worlds like Douglas Adams
who doesn't love Douglas Adams who
started by right started with Doctor Who
yeah and actually hitchhikers read Dirk
Gently was actually who I understand it
was intended to be like a Fourth Doctor
story and then it never got made into a
TV story and then he like adapt that it
made it into Dirk Gently in the book yes
amazing
so that's wild even if there's like
there's a fair amount of someone like
Buffy similar things that I like more
than Doctor Who I can watch this and be
like oh there's the DNA of that show
yeah
flipping on one x-files I just brought
up and yeah monster of the week and I
feel like any modern show that's doing
monster of the week has a tip of the cat
for your doctor and then I think reverse
that I think that a lot of modern show I
mean I think I think a lot of Doctor Who
modern Doctor Who sorry I can put words
together a lot of I'm doing the doctor
thing I think a lot of modern Doctor Who
is inspired by shows like Buffy like I
think you can definitely see the Steven
Moffat was a huge fan of what Buffy was
doing and that's why you have episodes
that are like Zeppo like you have a
Sweden esque yeah but like the like
blink is such a solid episode and I
think it's because Moffat like knew how
to write based on like what Buffy was
doing like we have so we're not gonna
put the Scoobies of the main characters
we're gonna make just just Xander yeah
and so I think blink is like what if we
didn't follow this character they needed
to do it for budget reasons but he
managed to like make that work as like a
standalone episode yeah so all right
let's that's enough positive
let's watch the trailer and we'll pause
and play as these are want
from fancy PBS comes a show that takes
place anywhere in the universe at
anytime the planets present with nature
where anything can happen and none of
the continuity matters do any matters as
long as it's yeah the thing that didn't
make it in and I didn't even end up
writing it for a cutscene is like the
continuity as pertains to time-travel
like trying to follow in my head the
rules of time-travel in this show and
yeah I couldn't couldn't do I gave up
there they're all showing me yeah there
are some but again it's it's something
they can be thrown out the window second
the plot needs it not to right yeah and
and I I will say at first I found this
very frustrating that they're just like
we'd already established that the doctor
can't go back to like a thing that's in
his own timeline then they'll do it
anyway and I was like well they think
they should explain like why here and
then I was like you know what I'm glad
they don't because that would just be
more of that dialogue of like make up
scientific sounding things like they
just go for it I mean I do have enough
they have one episode that explains it
but they also ever have that consequence
ever happen again whatever so does it's
Father's Day in Eccleston zerah there's
an episode where they go back in time
and rose stops her own father from dying
and then as a result that like it makes
a new timeline but because of that like
it's a world where this guy's not
supposed to exist and then also because
like it's the bootstrap paradox where
like well you wouldn't do that if you
can have time-travel but because you did
this you wouldn't have been on the time
machine so it's like a weird thing so
basically what happens is all the people
in the world start to vanish because
they're being eaten by like paradox
monsters I think I got a little taste of
those there was like a New York episode
where like New York shouldn't have
happened this way
yeah yeah there's something like that
isn't that also the plot of Stephen
King's the Langille ears I believe it is
they like get on a plane and then they
ever say very much like that and then
they are they enter like a it's like a
you can't like if you violate the
timeline you end up like out of time and
then the monsters coming to wrangle ears
it's like basically like every like
there's you know there is no timeline
like right once you move forward the
world is eaten every day all right nerds
let's keep code
the air because all the British nerds
who grew up with classic who finally got
old enough to call the shots at the BBC
now they're taking the stodgy old
formula and stretching it to an hour of
quirky comedy
I think soap opera pause funny stuff but
he said that that was I like that we
froze on the arch side yeah Eccleston
said that like I think his biggest
insecurity was he didn't think he was as
good at playing the comedy but he
actually does he have some pretty funny
lines throughout it but yeah yeah I
think that was like his big hang-up he's
a weird it is interesting to me that if
now now having seen as much of the show
as I have if it was 2005 you were like
hey let's reboot Doctor Who you have the
whole world of British actors who you
gonna pick for this quirky fun alien who
goes adventures I would not like great
actors they didn't know it was gonna be
a hit like the last thing they done yeah
doctor was a failed TV movie he's famous
like it's not like he was already like a
really well-established like very
serious dramatic actor it's an it's an
odd surely because he and Russell have
worked together in a previous project I
wanted to work together again and then
they now they hate each other
well Russell is very very British about
it whereas Eccleston is very much like
there's people there that work that were
terrible yeah
but Russell's like he was my doctor and
I protect him is a very very very
British posh about it but like yeah they
didn't think was in be a hit at all like
one of the people that was up for it
when it was like being cast was Hugh
Grant I thought it would be a failure be
associated with it and then like he
actually says he regrets it like he
wished he had done it that would be a
very different special so that's part of
why he was being considered for like my
favourite doctor Rowan Atkinson mr. bean
yeah yeah that's always that'll always
be my doctor all right you've got alien
who named himself that is a vow the name
I chose is
it's like a promise you make even though
the word doctor was created to describe
him he's a faulty tortoise from the
planet Gallifrey who sometimes kind of a
dig funny little human brains how do you
get around in those things with the
casual viewers he's a funny man with the
time machine who takes ladies on
adventures who's also kind of a dick
real time equipped with a time machine
with the power to break when the plot
needs to slow down but the TARDIS buzzed
so many things we didn't make in because
the TARDIS is also infinitely large yeah
oh I don't know if I knew that powered
by the ocean by a waves by an but the
dinosaurs on a spaceship ship really
yeah the TARDIS basically powered by the
vortex the time vortex yeah but there
were waves that's a that's a dinosaur
[ __ ] yes it's not a switch an infinitely
big but it's it's a pocket dimension and
it's infinitely big in that any room
that is needed it can but they really
only required that one standing set yeah
there were like three levels to it there
was like the the Wardrobe level right
and then there was like the main engine
room level and then I think there was
like one other areas like a catwalk
thing below it right it's expansive but
I don't I don't think anybody ever
mentioned in my episode but it's also
its scent there's an episode yeah it's
it's a living ship yeah there's an
episode in Matt Smith's Ron called
journey the center of a TARDIS yeah and
it's also the doctors white episode
where they go into the engine room
lava versions of them nutrients oh yeah
yeah and like it's one of the things
that we use later on here but where Rory
is like I waited for you again because
like at the Timeship and is like times
torsions like like one room
might be in and somebody else is in the
hallway but 60 years passed in this room
and they don't hear because time
distortion and then was the TARDIS soul
or spirit is infused into a human body
we find out its name is sexy yeah doctor
calls it yeah it's like all this if
there is l33 seven anyway it was
fighting for TARDIS right no brakeless
we didn't keep exploding inside of it
it's just a thought to the spatial
justice warrior travel all around the
universe from the streets of London to
working-class British mining town to the
quaintest UK as the center of the
universe
oh yeah people know they're very old
people but when the budget allows you'll
fly off into America it was supposed to
Mexico once in America is a huge deal it
was almost Italian setting a very cute
girl because ratings who after a few
seasons of adventure usually has her
life ruined faint imprisoned they were
tortured my mum my dad sister
if she's lucky I like when I shot them
someone to talk to and act is this
mostly ppattani but not always love
interest no they're basically dating
without the sex
except for nardole that one was purely
physical I'm not just sexy to franchise
so I think LAN and I both struggled with
the the love but not love between doctor
and companion oh yes I'm sure the fact
that it ever got consummated is super
weird
super weird thousand years old she's a
human woman
well River sort of River I mean she's
not she's a River rose right well they
never actually show them consummating
like that's it I am on that see I'm on
born with you I I have a hard time with
any sort of fiction where someone is
like centuries old and so that's why
like it's not only age it's not only age
it's like it's he's so in control of
everything like he's this alien he's
genius he's got the time he should like
the companions are so at his mercy that
it's like weird to inject a physical
like emotional relationship into that I
don't go as far on that one but there is
definitely like even River has the
speech in the husband's River a song or
it's just like trying to think the
doctor would love you back is like
thinking that a star would love yes yeah
but he definitely leads them on that
like he's flirting with Amy I maintain
for like the first two seasons that
they're together yeah yeah we've had
that discussion yes definitely yes very
much into her and she is very much not
into her husband but that's I don't
agree but she runs away on the eve of
her wedding yes because she's terrified
of what's good she has this whole thing
it's a fairy tale I'm shy I do I do I
will I will maintain that I do think
that Amy deeply loves Rory I think she
just yeah fine but like okay I'm a
married man if my wife the night before
our wedding went off with her love of
her life originally Jim Carrey if she
had run off the coast is Ventura that's
okay but Ace Ventura who she loved as a
child and I would be like oh my same
thing no because
but sure I didn't personally arrived at
her home and have her quit every did I
would seriously reconsider and compete
with that people didn't spend her whole
life telling her she was crazy because
she believed in these four days bender
would she showed up I'd like oh my god
this is the thing that I whole life I
wanted and like now it's suddenly
happening how would you not take that
opportunity like like it's it's bare
yeah at the end of the day when she does
get faced with a choice she chooses Rory
hmm eventually she and I both think your
wife could reasonably leave you afraid
that's what we're saying I'm not saying
that she doesn't have doubts I'm saying
like like she is scared and doesn't know
what she wants to do and like it's like
having a crisis or a cold feet and then
yes she's gonna go take this guy for a
test bit and see see how she comes she
chases him across a bed he has to hide
from her advances to prove that some of
the relationships are weird is that some
of them aren't and you know immediately
like the doctor and bill that's not
weird
they're not their friends even the
specter of romance oh I wish and chip I
think that show is better based on the
two seasons that I watched all the way
through like Capaldi and Clara nowhere
near as fun as Capaldi and Bill and I
like a lot of people hate Clara just in
looking around online oh yeah there's a
locker I hate which I don't I don't
understand I do not sanction that Clara
hate because like finally someone's
putting this weird old alien man in his
place it's nothing against the character
of Clara who I liked it was just like
they're kind of playing with this love
stuff that I don't know if it plays my
issue with Clara is mostly that I feel
like she's very inconsistent Lee written
yes because that like there are some
time before she's like this control
freak no times when she's not and I
think it's I don't think it's a
detriment of Jenna Coleman's acting I
think it's actually very good actor and
I think when it when they give her
different versions of the character play
she plays them all well like I think
that the the Dalek Clara we meet the
first time like the Oswin one I think
the Victorian one's usually good and
then when he plays Bonnie the Saigon and
yes he's a nine I think like so like
she's a very reined talented yeah but
they didn't have as clear of an arc with
her no part of its because she was
supposed to leave and then they're like
and then she's had to stay and then we
have to write a different arc for her
now and so that's part of it yeah and I
make sense tomorrow you know anyways
keep
it's been running for so long
they built 13 read castings of the main
character into the lore then hit that
limit and pulled even more out of a
crack as nature brings a new spin to the
alien who's seen the Stars but looks
like he's never seen the Sun whether
it's echoes unit and only the man
regenerate due to creative differences
with a BBC David Tennant the
unquestioned master of steering sadly
into the middle distances Matt Smith who
combined the face of a handsome
twelve-year-old with the way the arms of
an inflatable tube man see a Peter
Capaldi and we imagine the duck yeah
never got married and moved to Vegas in
his 40s
I was being all down with a kid sata2
notice the first female doctor no matter
how she performs is one of the least
outrageous things this ridiculous show
has ever done the doctor has because in
plenty of episodes it's a lame
monster-of-the-week invasion of the very
spirit or something invisible to save on
the effects budget richer purposes or
something we've seen a million times
before but an alien or anything
- like the Cybermen emotionless robots
who can only be defeated by a renegade
Time Lord who considers themselves the
doctors arch-nemesis
but is in the middle of this list so you
do the math yeah I managed to dodge
pretty much the doctors really glad you
found a place for the Santa Claus
stuffed into crab metal homes who spend
their entire life shouting Connacht
ACOTA LaHaye the new planet newcomers
like the seasons where the world keeps
ending well just kidding he can reverse
the planets rotation right now this is a
run that I think we'll all see make
sense we spent so much of our lives
watching this show and it was a
recommendation from dan who watched the
classic stuff like cut this and I even
knowing that it doesn't make for the
funniest trailer refused because each
one of these jokes represents 24 hours
of television yeah and I would not let
it go down the drain I also think it's a
relevant part of the show and that the
show often like sets these huge arcs up
and then like nope you're mine because I
reset itself so on right yes - yeah like
we were talking a lot I was talking
earlier today about the fact that
everyone seems to always forget when
there's like major invasions a couple of
years ago oh sure and I think they have
to treat it that way because I think
that when you're writing a show that you
either have to go well for our show
about keep a lien x' we can't ever have
an invasion plotline yeah or you have to
go Oh every invasion hotline is like
there's no stakes because the people
don't people don't care they've been
abated so many times right so they have
to kind of go like yeah
being afro a reference to how the humans
talk about messing with the timeline
just I'm sure it happens once but just
once I'd like a like a victorian-era
person to see an alien and be like Satan
and just go catatonic like they take it
in stride all of history modern past
future that is like all right this is
your key let's listen the neck and the
next doctor Christmas special there's
the scene where like a giant Cyberman
like it's like it's a Godzilla's the
City of London like it's basically like
there's a Jaeger attacking London and
then like never mention again part of
the like British character of like stiff
upper lip you know okay you can only be
on Britain in the very small cubes
episode I think everyone in the UK has a
heart has like a blackout seizure or
heart attack yeah all just like and then
they they reverse the polarity or
whatever and cube zap them back to life
well there's evil ass Capaldi season
there's basically like this whole era
but like this like race of monks like
take over the planet and then the next
day like bills like they're all gonna
know about it now and like some girl
walks by and she just bored on her phone
like oh yeah I think they were filming a
movie or something I guess that's
believable keep going
loser for all eternity just kidding
he'll make a copy of himself and they'll
live happily ever after the season it
was the doctor copes with the
inevitability of his own death
JK Rowling he'll live as long as the
ship needs him to what I suppose one
more lifetime or the season is where
he's haunted by the knowledge that he's
triggered the genocide of his own people
no cop genocide you see little picture
me that he's just kidding and he
actually saved everyone but doesn't
remember it
no actually suggesting that we change
our own personal history
sure that'll work wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey whatever so run down your
nearest hallway
yeah you need the same hallway multiple
time pull a plan ahead of yours but I've
got a plan hi I've got a plan
yeah of course I have a plan and starts
spouting techno babble like the universe
depends on it wave a fan Cassadine
energy micro transmission of a cake
build a wave that sticks it into a
living receptacle and then it feeds off
their memory sucks atria anything
because you were about to get some of
the mystery with a bunch of momentum
killing serialization crammed into
service the diehards but after all is
said and done let's still try to be more
like the doctor never crews gonna be
never be cruel hard never be cowardly
just enjoy the ride no no the leftover
bad Wolf's bad wolf what you're gonna do
scary poppins
show me your Bo face the appearance of
the repeated meme Mars the Tim Harry and
Ron at the same time we knew ye master
of none spin-doctors the great glass
doctor Vader that time Rose was on sorry
Rory but you just die and try to make me
think tenets voice yes
every British actor Harry a lien guy
from the Brotherhood without banners
[Laughter]
that was a lot of who to get through it
wasn't so bad now let's see what that
classic series is all about six months
of your life gone was it was all worth
it and it was fun fun to do because when
else would I have had the time to just
get paid to watch Doctor Who yes charity
too it was it was all for a good cause
and it is interesting to go through a
whole show like this where you're really
thinking about all the connections like
it's a good way to cram it all into your
mind like I know Doctor Who a lot better
now than if I had just casually watched
a few seasons yeah laughter yeah
and now all uh I'll probably uh I'll
probably keep going I feel like I'm
gonna keep I wouldn't if you would ask
me when I started this project if I
thought I would become a doctor who'
viewer I don't think I would have said
yes and yet it's all do and wore me down
like a 4.5 billion year long ravaged on
a weird thing where you move a rock and
you wear it down over time with the
strength of your pot now is Doctor Who
on me let's see the deletes what didn't
make it where anything can happen
and none of the continuity matter what
there's a Seinfeld it's a show about
nothing this is a show about everything
special effects and enough soap opera
pop to choke a telenovela yeah modern
who is way more Buffy the Vampire Slayer
than the show it's supposed to be
continuing an act as is mostly platonic
but not always love interest no your to
Shawn bossy and your nose is all funny
basically the doctor is Tom Hanks and
the companion is Wilson the volleyball
[Music]
we know that Jeff that one was purely
physical
it's pg-13 Rick and Morty you stole a
time-freezing crystal from testicle
monsters I would have been happy to pay
for its summer but they don't exactly
sell them at Costco or Jodie Whittaker
the first woman to ever attempt the role
of a flighty emotional British dandy who
hates guns and loves people yeah I'm not
worried that joke is reversed the bus
yeah like a horny elephant it's not
supposed to make that noise you leave
the brakes on well then take them off
never nice starring blink and you're
recast time edge Lord hit it and quit it
a wolf in sheep's Linda Angela Chris buy
a rose Britney Spears torch mobster
Agent Coulson Mad Men de Pompadour and I
just stopped by dr. pompadour can't be
killed grave rebound rose oh the Bionic
Woman
this is Billy love songs it's not the
size on the outside that matters Bill
Nye the Science God Sherman from Peabody
and Sherman foot head looking ass boys
this ain't you nebula origins the
inconsistent girl the doctor who doesn't
like to use weapons sometimes and I
haven't which makes me the better person
no no weapons it's not what I do things
the doctor uses weapons
you wouldn't cyber weapons hearts beat
the old Capaldi pick out
isn't it I'm not a hugger of Steel yeah
yeah it's lucky that nobody recorded
that wait a minute we did really a
horrible over here since that died this
is one that I I it shows just show me a
strange really strange doctor why is
done I thought you later with the best
one I think I think days are Eliza
future yeah the future passes really
good yeah wow that was something what a
journey
Thank You Riley thanks for having me
you've been indispensable I was glad to
be well yeah we could not have done this
without ya
thank you on oh you said okay and thank
you Joe who's I hope not lost in the
backwoods of Kentucky and is doing well
my favorite thing of when Joe would just
tweet the words doctor who also like
that cuz Joe and I have a friends for a
while and Joe has picked on me
mercilessly for years from loving this
show cuz he knows I get to rise out of
me
he loves to call the TARDIS the tandy
over the course the last six months
Jonah for somebody who did that to
someone who has now released his own
independent album of how far we've come
yeah I don't know what more is there to
say I feel like we covered it yeah I
feel I feel like just don't be cruel and
don't because I'm behind catch doctor
who Sunday's Sundays ABC marries in
America I don't want to go and yeah I
wish we had more but but it's hard to
say goodbye
but now I guess we have free time to do
other things like watch the classic show
now yeah I would probably we can catch
up on all this radio droning actually
pretty good I'm just gonna say if you
want to get some good poem again
action all right thank you so at Riley
Jay Silverman and Twitter at lawns
that's me that's Ben Jay Gilbert tweet
us your doctor thoughts will be watching
along with yeah yes and yeah yellow dust
there thanks for watching this show
we'll be back next week with something
much shorter I don't know what it will
be but it'll be a lot easier and
probably less fun so thanks a lot for
joining us bye-bye
[Music]
you